dans quelques semaines une aventure
unique prendra le départ dans l'arctique
canadien
le but de l'expédition québécoise accord
2021 comprendre comment se comporte le
corps humain confronté au défi de
traverser le canada du nord au sud en
pleine nature sauvage
[Musique]
des journées ou sulser ce met le couteau
entre les dents puis c'est là il me
donne tout ce que tu as parce qu'il faut
que ça avance de paul choix
c'est déjà fait dire mais vous savez
pour preuve quand vous allez traverser
les régions parce que les ours polaires
des dangers comme ça vous avez papa on a
pas on a très peur c'est justement ce
qui fait qu'on peut rester en vip
au mois de mars prochain cinq amis
effectueront une expédition extrême
alors le projet c5 c'est faire la plus
longue traversée jamais tentée du canada
dans son axe nord sud
à force humaine et sans interruption les
grandes statistiques ces trois mois des
skis pour environ 2000 km c'est un autre
de 1000 kilomètres de canaux qu'on veut
faire en deux mois
et pour finir avec 1 4000 km de vélo
qu'on va faire environ un mois donc sept
mille cent kilomètres en tout pour ces
sept modes d'expédition
avouons le la ventura corps 2021
requiert une dose de courage et un brin
de folie
on a beaucoup de risques à gérer et tu
sais pas une question de témérité le
service une question de capable de
cerner c'est quoi les risques tous les
jarry ans par an pour le spécialiste en
physiologie et en nutrition angelo
tremblay l'expédition accorde 2021
représente une mine d'or d'informations
en transformant ces explorateurs un
sujet scientifique il pourra mesurer
l'impact d'une expédition extrême
ça nous permet de documenter au moins
deux questions qui sont d'intérêt
particulier pour nous la première c'est
mieux connaître le corps humain de mieux
connaître les limites du corps humain
en ce qui a trait à sa capacité de
s'adapter à certaines situations très
dérangeant dans le contexte de
l'expédition accord on va mesurer les
sensations d'appétit on va être capable
aussi d'estimer l'apport alimentaire et
à ce moment là nous savons nous donner
de l'information relative à ce qu'ils
aient mangé par rapport à ce qui est
ressenti
qu'est ce qu'on en a mais on n'est pas
tout le barda l'achèteront on se prépare
à l' aventure depuis deux ans en plus de
la logistique
on se soumet un entraînement intense et
variée
[Musique]
et d'ici mars 2021
il faut développer une foule d'habileté
[Musique]
donc le maniement d'armes dans nord du
canada
l'ours n'est jamais bien loin
mars 2020 par un an jour pour jour ce
sera le grand départ en guise de
préparation les explorateurs décide de
s'aventurer sur le réservoir manicouagan
un terrain de jeux de 2000 kilomètres
carrés l'endroit parfait pour tester
leur matériel et pour accumuler de
l'expérience
huit heures de ski à -40 en train train
hot 200 à liv en mangeant bien centre
déshydraté alors une bonne gestion de
ton de ta chaleur puis de ton humidité
mais ça s'apprend et ça se pratique mais
avant leur départ vers le réservoir
manicouagan angelo tremblay a besoin de
données
on va faire un test sur tact et moulin
pendant lequel on mesure
l'électrocardiogramme la fréquence
cardiaque
la consommation d'oxygène quivogne au
permettent d'estimer la dépense
d'énergie durant l'expédition une
augmentation de la consommation
d'oxygène ces données seront comparées à
celles prises durant les sept mois de
l'expédition accord 2021 nos
explorateurs va mesurer leur fréquence
garcia à l'aide d'un moniteur qu'on
utilise pour l'entraînement
habituellement vont mesurer bien sûr
leur teint d'exercice vont remplir un
questionnaire relativement à la qualité
du sommeil vont aux mesures et
périodiquement leurs sensations
d'appétit et on saura assez précisément
combien de calories auront été dépensés
durant l'effort pendant l'expédition
ce matin c'est le départ vers le
réservoir manicouagan
elron cette heure avant d'y arriver
[Musique]
devant te un terrain de jeu d'un blanc
immaculé
durant trois semaines cette nature
deviendra leur demeure
la journée débute vers 8h15 par une
randonnée de quatre heures par suite une
petite pause le temps de dîner
un moment d'une importance cruciale la
streak la bouffe c'est la relation
primordial c'est sûr j'aurais presque
aussi importante que la relation entre
les membres d'équipages pour la simple
et bonne raison qu'en fascine car murat
d'alors il se pourrait bien que leurs
dépenses énergétiques soit augmenté de 2
à 3000 calories par jour par rapport à
ce qu'elle serait ici ils étaient
sédentaires
c'est une estimation on verra qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire
c'est leur fréquence cardiaque qu'on va
rapporter à nos variable de laboratoire
mesuré avant et à crack qui vont nous
donner le des chiffres précis sur cette
question là
après le repas un autre quatre heures de
ski et comme c'est toujours le cas
la glace dicté le tempo enfin on est
devant une feuille puis a pas assez
épais de classe pour passer on a à peu
près un pouce de glace s'est passé pour
nous supporter même en rampant il faut
contourner l'obstacle
normalement on pense que plus loin par
le il va avoir moins d'eau puis la glace
va être plus ferme japon supporter
et puis en fin d'après midi on remonte
la tente en terrain hostile
il ne faut rien négliger ajuster notre
système d'alarmé en fait ces systèmes de
détecteurs de mouvements de chaleur est
ce assez pour nous avertir lorsqu'il ya
un ours polaire proche de la tente
les nuits sont froides balayé par les
vents à -40 degrés celsius la glace
crack l'attend bouge sur le mouvement
des glaces plus d'entendre si ces
craquements sinistre là on a vraiment
l'impression d'entendre des tambours en
dessous de notre temps cette expédition
n'en serait pas une sans son lot
d'anecdotes et d'épais ni corps est
tombé dans l'eau hier ils l'ont fait et
puis on des glaces libre en attendant
les semelles pour qu'ils puissent dormir
avec cette nuit on est tout seul en
forme manger le bout du nez un peu un an
de leurs riffs brûlé par le froid
l'expédition sur le réservoir
manicouagan a été un très bon test
quelques ajustements seront apportés en
vue du grand départ
par exemple on prévoyait pas autour de
23 kilomètres par jour pour moyen d'un
journal à sa puce tourne autour de 18
veille sept mois d'expédition ou pour un
projet unique qui demandera pied plus
que de la forme physique de la
détermination on aime le défi
on aime se dépasser et à quelque chose
d'absolument unique il est tellement
merveilleux d'évoluer par toi même en
autonomie complète dans un territoire
qui est aussi sauvage aussi peu
dénaturée
[Musique]